Ivan says take us back to the day when
you said yes to Jerome Jarre what was it
that made you believe in him and his
idea Thanks
I've been great question for the ones
out there that don't know drunk Jar a
very famous vine or snapchat or
Instagram er and I started an agency
called grapes story a sister agency to
vaynermedia all those characters last
May where we represent the best talent
in the emerging content platforms to do
branded content and things of that
nature
Jerome beat me in rock-paper-scissors in
Toronto and what he won on stage Jerome
raised his hand and said I was doing Q&A
can I go up there and play you
rock-paper-scissors if I beat you can I
have coffee with you in New York I said
yes I got him up there and I was
hell-bent on beating him and if I won I
swear my children I would have never met
with him so just amazing how life really
is he wins pissed me off and you know
three months later I look at my calendar
I'm like what's my next meeting it's
like 10:30 at night on a Tuesday I'm
dead I just want to go home and like
what's my next meeting
Jerome I'm like what is this I clickin I
don't even know the name I click into it
for the details that's how my calendar
kind of I do and I'm like oh this guy I
literally thought I was like all right
how do I get there and spend four
minutes in this meeting get out of there
and go to sleep because I'm 5:30 flight
which was like a 3:45 wake-up call the
next day I remember and and Jerome
started talking he's like look there's a
platform by and I've got all in I'm an
entrepreneur I've grew up in France and
went to China I learned how to speak
English by listening to crush it on
audio which played to my ego so that
made me sit there longer and then and
then he just kept talking and basically
was deja vu it felt like I was having a
conversation 2006 except Jerome was me
and I was Eric Kastner my lead developer
that I've given a lot of shout out to I
was pitching cash for in 2006 should I
started a record label I don't even know
about agents and things like that
I remember saying should I started I
remember the moment in his office should
I start a record label to represent
these new YouTube stars like me
I should have and but I let it go and
Jerome was talking I'm like this is the
same moment over again and so the energy
my gut feel the fact that I believed in
what he was talking about he wanted to
do a festival we turned it into an
agency because that's what I knew about
and so that's what that's what it was it
was the content the context and the
intuition and when I have that a CCI
concoction I always go with it oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe